[Music]
hello gq thank you for having me i'm
jeremy allen white these are my
essentials
so right here i have my uh
moleskine
uh journal i don't know what i have kind
of written in here now
uh some drawings it looks like from uh
from my daughters but mostly it's for
kind of like organizing my thoughts i
have a hard time figuring out my days so
i'll make a list in here and this is
where
i keep my scripts il besante they're
really really beautiful
they work in leather they also make bags
and stuff i got my first one which is
like kind of a
darker leather from a really good friend
gary goldman for my 21st birthday and i
always have one of these on set with me
i bought these for the whole cast of
shameless as a wrap gift when we
finished on the inside
i had this put in it says um
one bad turn deserves another if you're
familiar with shameless there's like
this staircase that goes down into the
gallagher kitchen in the gallagher house
and there was a little sign on it that
said one bad turn deserves another and
so i would stare at that sign all the
time for 11 years so this is in all of
them got uh i guess the last thing i
worked on was the bear and i guess i was
hanging onto the pilot episode for a
long time oh tattoos
i didn't know these were in here but uh
these are all of carmi's tattoos from
the bear i have a buddy benny shields
who's a really wonderful tattoo artist
and he helped me design all of them
these angels
uh i thought maybe carmi would have
gotten
when his brother was still alive uh that
maybe he would have gotten for for his
sister and his brother uh they're right
here carmy's tattoos extras
that's a pyrex with the world in it sou
sense of urgency
always i don't know if that's always on
time i don't think i actually use this
one but yeah it was interesting to kind
of
get to know a character through tattoos
and really discuss
where and why he got these things and
kind of make discoveries about a
character through that process i'd never
done it before i think for carmi they're
sort of a
sort of an armor i don't think he felt
that tough all the time and
that got him here
okay so um
this is
this is a new york mets hat not to be
confused with a yankees hat a lot of
people ask me
if this was pre-distressed and very
expensive it wasn't it's a normal hat
i wear it a lot and i wash it a lot and
it's just really beat i think it's
honestly probably on its uh its last
legs but i'm really gonna wear it until
it's all done i grew up watching the
yankees but my wife is truly a die hard
mets fan
uh so i switched up
probably like seven years ago
and started rooting for the mets
um i guess
that's love
i've got my little like a weekender bag
and
these things pretty much live
in that bag and i've got like probably
like five or six notes in there from uh
from my wife but if if i'm going
anywhere she'll
write me a note and she'll often times
write a note from our three-year-old our
three-year-old can't write yet so my
wife will write one for her it's so nice
you know when when you're missing home
to have them close i usually have them
on like the table right next to my bed
and yeah i'll read them when i wake up
before i go to bed
middle of the day i love reading them um
i miss them and it makes me think of
them when i'm away
and then these it's a little bit weird
we ended up like uh
a couple years ago with all these single
socks and we didn't know what to do with
them um so
so my wife and i started taking them
with us whenever we went anywhere our
daughters have stuffed animals um that's
their sort of safety blankets and uh and
we have these safety socks um
we love them it makes us feel close to
them so um
so yeah we take them around
[Music]
okay uh this is diptyque candle um
i was introduced to these candles by a
fancy friend a couple years ago i
have them all over our house and
whenever i go anywhere to do a job or or
really go anywhere um i'm obviously
missing home a lot um so i'll always
pick these up
uh just to give me
that little sense of home yeah yeah yeah
specifically the fig um that is that is
my favorite
another thing i i really take with me
everywhere
are these sneakers white on white nike
cortez um
i usually i'll keep like
one pair that's kind of clean um in case
i want to wear it to something nice um
but then i definitely like the way
that they look once they get beat up and
i have like a kick around one as well
that's just my everyday shoe nike stop
making white on white uh cortez like a
year ago um it's like a 60 shoe now
they're on stockx for like 250 300.
maybe you guys at gq could help me out
i'm sure you know some people over at
nike but yeah so this one is actually
i think this is like a women's size 12.
my best friend gabe gomez
found these for me i love the shoe i
love the shape of it it's super
comfortable you can exercise in them
it's been probably like six years of me
wearing the shoe
and i'll never stop so nike please
help me out more
more white on white nike cortez thank
you
this is a little speaker it's called a
boombot rex i don't think they make them
anymore um obviously there are a lot of
good portable speakers out there um
i really like this one it's super
durable and i usually wear it while i'm
riding my bike that's how i get around
in new york i have a lot of friends and
i know there's a lot of people out there
that have their
air pods in their ears while they're
riding their bike
i'm worried about you guys you've got to
be paying attention to stuff this is
nice it's got a really nice sound
you can hear what you're listening to
and make phone calls but you can also
remain aware of what's going on around
you which is important when you're
riding your bike right now
i'm listening to like a lot of gold link
jimmy cook's on the
playlist for this summer
i've got you're the one on the playlist
i've got some ll cool j around the way
girl yeah a lot of a lot of new york
artists
okay so we have um
s and b crunchy garlic oil um
this is something
that we found during the pandemic
we started
going out and getting these orders from
uh like cookbook in la which is like a
really lovely sort of like specialty
grocery store and they threw this in the
bag one day and yeah it's great and it
goes on anything you can put it on
sandwiches uh eggs um
obviously like rice and like noodle
dishes are really really great i
discovered this before
the bear came around uh and i was really
useless in the kitchen so
this was especially helpful since then
we started the bear and
i've learned a couple more things and
yeah i will have this everywhere with me
it's uh
it's delicious
i have these gloves you can pick them up
anywhere they're like 299 399 really
inexpensive i have a lot of them i'm
always losing them i'll find a park with
an outdoor gym
that's how i like to exercise i'll bring
some jump rope and
i'll do some pull-ups
push-ups dips all that stuff
all that stuff can be pretty rough on
your hands they make you look pretty
serious i like exercising outside
especially in new york in these uh in
these outdoor
uh gyms in the parks because there's
always going to be someone there that's
tougher than you
so i find that i'll get sort of quietly
competitive um and
i'll end up training a little bit harder
whenever
you do pull-ups you should take your
rings off so i'm going to talk a little
bit about my jewelry
[Music]
this is really the first piece of
jewelry
that i ever started wearing that's just
a
nice little w my last name is white
and i actually i bought this for
my father for christmas
but he's got really big fingers and they
didn't fit so
it became mine this is just a really
simple little gold chain and
on it here is a new york subway token
i grew up here in new york uh my father
had a big jar of these growing up in our
apartment
um and now everybody in the family has
one my sister wears one around her neck
my mother
my wife does she's also from new york uh
my dad has one this one's really sweet
my wife had this one made
um
that's my daughter's name there that's
ezzer and i'll give it uh to ezzy one
day i'm sure so i'm just keeping it safe
for until uh until she can she can put
it on this one is this really really
nice ring and in there it's just a e and
a d for for my daughters um ezr and
dolores
i love the shape of it i love the shape
of kind of like
all our stuff it's like
kind of masculine and feminine at the
same time um and yeah that's uh that's
my jewelry and my wedding ring is right
here but that's all of it yeah
facial fuel uh from keels i don't do a
lot of stuff for my face uh
i wash it with water warm water uh and
then i put
this stuff on um it's got spf it smells
nice makes me feel good um
i feel like with this
i don't need much else even if that
might not be completely true we were
shooting the bear in chicago in january
and february so i would be putting this
on
all throughout the day your skin gets
really dry i love to go to um
like bath houses so i always make sure i
have this if i'm going to any of the
korean spas in la or my favorite bath
house the russian turkish bath house in
this village here in new york
a book it's important i always have a
book with me this book
is the one i'm kind of reading right now
but
i find it important to take a book with
me even if i don't read it wherever i'm
going
you don't want to be out there looking
like a bozo
you should always have a book with you
i doubt
i will finish it i don't often finish
books um
but you should always have a book with
you uh don't get caught out there
traveling
without a book um gq
thank you so much for having me um
i hope you guys all got to know me a
little bit better
um
this is me here on the table
and i truly do want to know
about the nikes uh i could use your help
um i love these shoes i don't know what
i'll do without them so
let me know thank you guys